what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and yesterday we got
one division
episode eight only one more one division
episode to go before the series ends
and although they've revealed a lot
about wanda vision in the past couple of
episodes there's still
a lot that needs to happen and right now
with a combination of
theories leaks and simple predictions we
could probably narrow down a few things
that have to happen
in one vision episode 9 the grand finale
but if you have not seen
one division episode 8 or any of the
episodes before it this is your spoiler
warning you should probably click away
now unless you don't care
and of course if you're new and you love
marvel be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos
so the first thing that we need to
address is the fact that white vision
ghost vision grey vision whatever you
want to call him the version from the
west coast avengers
vision is now in one division and it's
very clear now that the vision that
wanda created her vision
is going to have to fight hayward's
vision so we're going to have paul
bettany acting
with himself in an episode so we have to
talk about that secret cameo that paul
bettany was
teasing could this actually be himself
this actor that he said he's always
wanted to work with that he's had
really good chemistry with that he
worked very well with on the set could
it actually just be
himself could he be trolling us there is
a chance and if that's the case i'm
going to be pretty upset but also at the
same time
pretty funny move by paul however let's
not forget that elizabeth olsen did
confirm that there is going to be
indeed a huge cameo from somebody and we
haven't seen
the engineer yet so a big cameo is going
to be coming and a final
huge fight is going to be coming of
course as well and one thing that's
going to happen that seems to be kind of
obvious at this point is that wanda is
going to have to kill vision
all over again hayward's new version of
vision is essentially ultron
and ultron is pretty much now a puppet
for hayward
it's almost like he has a remote control
vision to kind of do whatever he wants
and right now he hates wanda he even
lied about her breaking into the
facility to kidnap vision's body which
of course we found out in the last
episode
is absolutely not true wanda was
actually pretty civil about the whole
entire thing she went in said goodbye to
vision and left without harming anybody
but hayward being the director of sword
the sentient
weapon observation response division
kept his body and created from him
a sentient weapon and there's no doubt
that he is going to send this weapon
this version of vision after wanda who
is responsible for taking over these
people
and the city of west view now wanda is
going to have her family with her but
just judging by the way that
everything's been happening for wanda
all of the trauma that she's had to face
during her life it's most likely going
to be her that's going to have to kill
this version of vision
kind of reliving her pain all over again
and then of course there's a possibility
that the actual vision that wanda
created will not make
it out of the reality this vision won't
survive either we have seen him outside
of the hex and it doesn't seem like he
is allowed to leave and it seems like if
he stays outside of the hex he will in
fact die
and i definitely think it's safe to
assume that one division is going to end
with the
hex disappearing so it's not only
looking like one vision is going to die
but
both visions are going to die but the
same can't be said
for wanda's children she didn't actually
create them with her magic
well sort of but she actually birthed
them she actually became pregnant and
had her kids
and of course we know that the young
avengers are coming so it would make
sense that billy and tommy or
wiccan and speed would be a part of the
young avengers therefore it would make
sense that they would survive
and again wanda didn't simply create
them like she did vision she actually
had them
so they could probably survive outside
of the heck since they are actually
real humans or they could technically be
mutants and speaking of mutants we still
have evan peters's fox version of
quicksilver
in one division and we didn't see him in
episode 8 the last time that we saw him
was episode 7 in the post credit scene
where he had
monica rambo now of course i got the
hardness revealed that she was
possessing
this person in order to obtain
information from wanda to figure out
how she created everything how she cast
so many spells at once and had
thousands of people under control so
he's an actual person he isn't a
creation of her
and since we're about to dive into the
multiverse of madness he
very well could be the quicksilver from
the fox universe and
vision has the power to awaken him he
has the power to take him out of
agatha's spell
and if he does so that would probably
mean that since agatha is the one that
hexed him he would be fighting alongside
wanda vision and of course her twins and
that brings us to the final battle there
are going to be a lot of people involved
in this battle
now before the post credit scene of one
division episode 8 we assumed that it
was going to be
wanda vision her twin boys wiccan and
speed
monica rambo with her new powers making
her photon or spectrum
and awakened quicksilver fighting along
with a team all against
agatha harkness but now we know that
hayward's vision is going to be joining
the picture as well
and we know that this vision is going to
go after wanda but
is this vision also going to go after
agatha or is agatha going to have some
sort of an ally in this battle
vision vs vision seems indefinite at
this point in time so
maybe when the two visions are fighting
agatha will be fighting
wanda her twins quicksilver and monica
at the same time
however i do have a theory about agatha
harkness that could take us in a
different direction
perhaps she's not actually bad in one
division she doesn't really seem to be
doing
everything that she's doing because
she's evil she actually seems to be
doing everything because she's scared
now when we had agatha's little theme
song stating that she was behind
everything she wasn't actually
responsible for creating this reality
and controlling the people
yes she did influence some events that
have happened but she didn't start it
all and the reason that she did
influence some events that happened is
because she wanted to figure out how
wanda started it all agatha came to west
view because she sensed the spells that
wanda cast
and she wanted to know who cast these
spells who was responsible
for all of this power for controlling
all these people
this scared agatha because she knew what
this was she knew that it was an
extremely
powerful being she came to west view
realized it was wanda who did everything
but wanted to know how she did it she
wanted to know
how she was this powerful and then in
the last episode of one division she
finally realized how she did it
she realized that wanda is a scarlet
witch and she has
chaos magic and this scares agatha so
agatha seems to be approaching wanda
and everything that has happened not
from an evil side but
a curious side which then eventually led
into
a scared side so it could be possible
that agatha
isn't actually bad she just fears wanda
for what she is a scarlet witch
so perhaps if she finds out that wanda
can indeed be good
kind of like agatha's mother told her
during the salem witch trials
perhaps agatha could actually be friends
with wanda and let her live
especially if she has some type of
mentor or coach which is where the next
theory comes in
that doctor strange is going to show up
at the end of one division
paul bettany said that the final battle
of one division is going to have
more cgi than avengers in game had and
if you consider the fact that there are
two witches going to fight each other
and a junior witch wiccan who will most
likely be involved somewhat in the fight
we can assume that there's going to be a
lot of
magic involved in this final fight which
would require that cgi
and there's no way a huge final magical
battle is going to go down without
doctor strange sensing this
agatha harkness picked up on the magic
that was going on in west view and
granted she is a lot older than doctor
strange is and a lot more experienced we
can still assume that doctor strange
will eventually pick up on the magic
that is happening
after all it is doctor strange's
responsibility to protect
this reality that the main mcu is in he
stated that in avengers infinity war
when he told tony stark which brings us
to the final theory that at the end of
one division
wanda will go with doctor strange now
this is in fact confirmed the president
of marvel studios has already told
us that one division will tie directly
into doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness and
wanda is going to be one of the main
characters of the film in fact elizabeth
olsen is already shooting for the movie
but again dr strange said his job was
protecting the reality
and it's now revealed that wanda has
reality warping
powers chaos magic and this is not good
for doctor strange who tries to protect
reality so this has to be the key of why
doctor strange
actually takes wanda under his wing he
needs her to learn how to control
this reality warping magic so it doesn't
actually affect their reality
he can't have wanda being a threat to
the universe so he takes her under his
wing
however i still think that her chaos
magic comes from the elder
demon god c'thun i believe that just
like in the comics he
marked her therefore giving her part of
his chaos magic
and i think that this could be the main
villain of doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
now just to address one final thing that
i've been hearing a lot of theories
about
the theory that hayward is actually
ultron it is a great theory however i
don't believe this to be true
i think he's just a jerk i think he's
afraid of super powered individuals
which is why he wanted to use vision's
body to essentially create an ultron
that he can control but i do not think
that he himself is ultron but we'll find
out in less than a week now in the
meantime let me know what you think
about all these theories and leaks in
the comments down below and let me know
what you think is going to happen
in the final episode of wanda vision
don't forget to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest one
division news give the video a like and
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof